اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
الجيش الاوكراني في اي تقدم روسي في بخموت
يحذر من تداعيات وخيمه لخساره المدينه
مع استمرار المفاوضات حول التعديلات
القضائيه في اسرائيل رسائل شديده اللهجه
بين بايدن ونتنياهو
واشنطن تحذر بكين من اي رد فعل على زياره
رئيسه تايوان والصين تعتبر
الترانزيتا متعمدا
تقرير يحذر بان الذكاء الاصطناعي سيحل محل
ثلاثه 300 مليون وظيفه بدوام كامل على
الاقل في المستقبل
صباح الخير مشاهدينا نبدا من معركه طويله
الامد خسارتها مكلفه للطرفين اوكرانيا
وروسيا لذلك يخوض جيش البلدين قتالا شرسا
في باخموت وتضاربا في الانباء حول التقدم
الروسي فيها الجيش الاوكراني اكد ان
القوات الروسيه لا تزال تحاول السيطره على
بخموت وابديفكا الشرقيتين من دون احراز
تقدم هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه قالت ان معظم الهجمات الروسيه
تتركز على بلدتي باخموت وافديفيا
والمجتمعات القريبه منهما في منطقه
الصناعيه واشار متحدث باسم قوات الجيش
الاوكراني الى تسجيل سبعين قصفا روسيا في
باخموت وحدها وان المقاتلين الاوكرانيين
مازالوا يتصدون للهجمات مع تكبد روسيا
خسائر كبيره في الارواح اثناء القتال وفق
قوله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بدوره حضر الرئيس الاوكراني من انه ما لم
تكسب بلاده معركه باخموت فقد تبدا روسيا
في بناء دعم دولي لاتفاق قد يتطلب من
اوكرانيا تقديم تنازلات غير مقبوله
سيبيع بوتين هذا النصر سيبيع هذا النصر
للغرب ولمجتمعه وللصين ولايران ولجميع
البلدان الى البرازيل الى دول امريكا
اللاتينيه وليس الى لاتيا وليتوانيا
واستونيا
خلال تصريحاته وجه الرئيس الاوكراني
دعوه للرئيس الصيني لزياره اوكرانيا
ايضا عن قلقه من تغيير موازين القوى
السياسيه في الولايات المتحده
ومميزات معركه بخموت الحاسمه مشاهدينا
قصفت القوات الاوكرانيه مدينه
روسيا جنوبي منطقه زابوريجيا ما ادى
الانقطاع امدادات الكهرباء في المدينه وعن
قرى مجاوره وفق وسائل اعلام روسيه وبحسب
وكاله تاس الروسيه جرى تدمير مستودع
للقطارات ايضا من دون وقوع اصابات وفقا
للمعلومات الاوليه كما افاد رئيس بلديه
ميريت بول بوقوع عده انفجارات في المدينه
من كييف ينضم الينا الصحفي محمد البابا
اهلا بك معنا محمد اذا ما اخر التطورات من
جانبكم حول المعركه المحتدمه في بخموت
نعم بالفعل يعني يقوم الجيش الاوكراني
باستهداف مراكز تواجد القوات الروسيه
المتواجده في الجهه الشرقيه لمدينه الجيش
الاوكراني ايضا يكثف عمليته في محيط باخ
مت عبر قصف مراكز تجمع القوات الروسيه
خاصه ان حركه الجيش الاوكراني قد تغيرت
كبير خلال الاسبوع يعني خلال الايام
القليله الماضيه بعد وصول يعني تعزيزات
عسكريه كبيره للجيش الاوكراني وذخائر بشكل
كبير ايضا القوات
[تصفيق]
في فتره الهواء قوي هنا
يعني الكويتيه الروسيه خلال الفتره
الاخيره خلال اليومين او ثلاثه ايام
الماضيه بدا ارسلت ايضا تعزيزات من قوات
المشاه والجيش الروسي النظامي الى منطقه
باكموت بسبب يعني تراجع حده القتال عند
مجموعات وبسبب النقص الكبير في العتاد
والسلاح وايضا العناصر لمجموعات الروسيه
ضخت مجموعات عسكريه كبيره لتصعيد كبير في
مدينه في محاوله للدخول واحتلال تلك
المدينه بشكل كامل خلال الفتره القليله
المقبله قبل بدء الجيش الاوكراني بالهجوم
المدرب ايضا الجيش الروسي بدا يفتح او
يقوم يعني اشعال بعض الجبهات الاخرى خاصه
على محور الايمان بالامس كان هناك قصف
شديد ومحاولات كثيفه من القوات الروسيه
للتقدم باتجاه لمن الا ان الجيش الاوكراني
قام بصد هذه العمليات ايضا الجيش
الاوكراني خلال يعني بالامس منع دخول
الصحفيين وطالب جميع المدنيين بمغادره
ادفيافكا بشكل فوري بسبب العمليات
العسكريه الشديده والهجوم الروسي الكبير
على مدينه
الجيش الاوكراني اعلن انه استلم عدد من
دبابات من بريطانيا من المانيا من شيكا
ومن بولندا اصبحت لدى القوات الاوكرانيه
ايضا فنلندا والنرويج ارسل الدبابات
لوبارد للجانب الاوكراني وايضا يعني الجيش
اوكرانيا وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه اعلنت
انها استلمت عدد من دبابات تشالنجر
البريطانيه التي ارسلتها بريطانيا وفي هذه
الاثناء محمد تشير او يشير مجلس الامن
الروسي في عاجل يريدنا على الشاشه انه لا
تر اجع عن تحقيق الاهداف المعلنه للعمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا شكرا لك كنت معنا من
كييف الصحفي محمد البابا
وعلى وقع تصاعد حدث المعارك في بخموت
اعلنت روسيا عن بدء تدريبات عسكريه على
صواريخ يارس النوويه البالستيه والعابره
للقارات التدريبات تجري بمشاركه اكثر من
3000 عسكري وبوجود 300 قطعه من المعدات
العسكريه ولكن السؤال مشاهدينا ما هي
صواريخ يارس وما مدى قوتها هي منظومه
استراتيجيه مزوده بصواريخ باليستيه عابره
للقارات يبلغ مداها اثني عشر الف كيلو متر
ما يسمح باصابه ابعد موقع في العالم
وبسرعه صاروخيه تبلغ 14 ماخ فضلا عن قوتها
التفجيريه التي تعادل مليون طن
في الاثناء تسلمت القوات المسلحه الروسيه
المئات من احدث الدبابات لاستخدامها في
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا وذلك
وفقا ما افادت به مصادر وكاله سبوتنيك
والتي اوضحت ايضا ان معظم الدبابات
الجديده من طراز تي 90 ام تسلمتها موسكو
من خط تجميع الدبابات في مجمع الصناعات
الدفاعيه الروسيه اما الخارجيه الروسيه
فقد وصفت قرار الولايات المتحده بحجب
بيانات نوويه بانه اخفاق خبيث وضار
للامتثال لمعاهده ستوريت وقال نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسي سيرجي ريابكوب قال ان
واشنطن لم تعلق مشاركتها رسميا في معاهده
وبناء على ذلك فهي ملزمه بالامتثال الكامل
لبنودها من موسكو ينضم الينا دبلوماسيه
السابق في جيجل اهلا بك معنا سيد لنبدا
بتصريحات روسيا بان امريكا
ملزمه بهذا الاتفاق الاتفاق لانها لم تخرج
منه رس ما تعليقك
طبعا امريكا خرجت من كل الاتفاقات دوليه
التي كانت في السابق تواقع مع الاتحاد
السوفييته مع روسيا فيدراليه على اساس
حقوق متساويه على اساس قانون الدولي عندما
امريكا كانت تعتبر انهم
المتحده القوه الاساسيه الوحيده في العالم
وروسيا تخرج من اثار سياش الامريكيه اصبحت
هناك كل الاتفاقيات الفاعله بين روسيا
وامريكا
فاشله خرجت امريكا من اتفاقيه الصواريخ
متوسطه الماده
صواريخ مضاده للصواريخ
نظام
الدفاعي كل هذه الخطوات لا شك ان اشاره
واضحه بالنسبه لروسيا
ولايات المتحده مش ملتزمه لكل الاتفاقيات
انا من جانبي انا شخصيا ممكن اضيفه انا
مثلا او دافي حركه اولمبيه العالميه حيث
فرضت على منظمه الرياضه مش السياسه مش
منظمات التحالفات العسكريه الرياضه منع
الرفع الاعلى الروسي هذا هو اساس هذا هو
حرب
يعني اردنا الحديث عن معركه بخمو تحديدا
والتي تقول روسيا بانها تحرز تقدما كبيرا
فيها ولكن الجانب الاوكراني في ذلك ولا
ننسى بان روسيا ايضا تقوم الان بتدريبات
عسكريه على صواريخ يارس النوويه البالستيه
العابره للقارات لماذا تقوم بهذه
التدريبات في هذا التوقيت الذي تقول بانها
تحرز فيه تقدما في بخموت هل هي تستعد ربما
لمعركه الربيع المرتقبه
اولا انه معركه محمود لحتى يفهم
صدقه المشاهدين انه معركه البحنوط مهمه
مهمه ليست استراتيجيا مهمه سياسيا ونفسيا
لان المعركه المخموت يخوضها من جانب
الروسي فقط شركه العسكريه خاصه
الذي
جيش اوكراني النظامي في في بحمو
ولذلك تقدم لهذا الشركه واضح تماما
ويحاربوا
لا شك ان عنصر الاعلامي يلي دورا كبيرا
وموقف وتصريحات الرسميه من قبل كذلك هم
يحاولوا ان يشجعوا
القوات اوكرانيه للمعركه ولكن تقريب محمود
تقريبا محاسب تاريخ واحد
يربط اوكرانيا مع محمود
وهذا الطريق تحت الضرب المكثف
لمدفعيه للصواريخ ولطيارات كل هذا لا يسمح
لاوكرانيين ان يزودوا
محمود قواتها في محمود
ماذا عن التدريبات على
يارس
5000 يوميا
طيب يبدو انك لم تسمعني سيد شكرا جزيلا لك
من موسكو الدبلوماسيه السابق
اثار قرار اللجنه الاولمبيه الدوليه غضب
روسيا فقد اوصت اللجنه باعاده الرياضيين
الروس والبيلاروس تدريجيا الى المحافل
الدوليه لكن تحت علم محايد وبصفه فرديه
شرطه عدم دعمهم للحرب ضد اوكرانيا وقال
الرئيس اللجنه توماس ان توصيات المجلس
التنفيذي للجنه تتعلق فقط بعوده هؤلاء
الرياضيين الى المنافسات الدوليه ولكن
المشاركه في اولمبياد باريس 2024 ستتطلب
قرار منفصلا يتخذ لاحقا من جانبه اعتبر
رئيس اللجنه الاولمبيه الروسيه معايير
اللجنه الدوليه غير مقبوله وقال ان الشروط
المقترحه لا اساس لها وتخالف القانون
ومجحفه مستمرون معكم ونتابع بعض الفاصل
تلميحات ايرانيه بابقاء الباب مفتوحا
لاستئناف المفاوضات النوويه
احييكم من جديد تستمر اليوم في اسرائيل
المفاوضات بين احزاب الغالبيه والمعارضه
بشان خطه الاصلاح القضائيه المثيره للجدل
واعلن مكتب الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق هرتز
المشاورات مستمره بعد لقاء اول جرى امس
انتهى بروح ايجابيه وفق بيان المكتب وعقد
او عقد لقاء الحوار الاول في مقر اقامه
هرتسوغ بين فرق العمل التي تمثل الائتلاف
الحاكم وحزبين معارضه يجع عتيد وحزب
الوحده الوطنيه وكان زعيمه حزبي يشعتيد
والوحده الوطنيه يائير اللبيد وبيني كانت
اعلى ناس تعدادهما للحوار مع الغالبيه
برعايه هرتوغ
ولكن بينما تخوض اسرائيل نقاشات مكثفه
مشاهدينا لحل ازمه التعديلات القضائيه
دخلت في سجال حاد مع اداره الرئيس جو
بايدن الذي وجه رساله شديده اللهجه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بايدن حذر في بيان من
ان اسرائيل لا يمكنها مواصله مسار
المواجهه القضائيه داعيا رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو للتوصل الى تسويه حقيقيه
وقال بشكل صريح انهم لا يعتزم دعوه الى
البيت الابيض في المدى القريب الاخير رد
ورفع لهجه السجال فقال ان اسرائيل دوله
مستقله تتخذ قراراتها من دون اي ضغوط
خارجيه ومن امام الكنيسه تنضم الينا
مراسله العربيه لنا كالغاصي اهلا بك معنا
لنا ما الجديد حول هذا السجال بين بايدن
ونتنياهو ما الجديد حول هذا حول المعارضه
والاتفاقيه التي وصفت بانها ايجابيه كانت
في اللقاء الاخير
يعني نبدا بالاجتماع الذي انعقد ليله امس
بين الاحزاب اليمينيه والائتلاف الحكومي
وبين المعارضه الاسرائيليه برئاسه يائير
لفيد كان هناك اجتماع ليله امس ولكن هذا
الاجتماع لم ينتهي بتسويه بين الطرفين
انما كان هناك فعليا روح ايجابيه حسب ما
وصفها الرئيس الاسرائيلي ولكن حتى الان لا
يوجد هناك اعلان عن فحوى ومضمون هذا
الاجتماع الذي استمر لمده ساعه ونصف في
منزل الرئيس الاسرائيلي هرتز ولكن يعني
التداعيات تقول بان فعليا هذا الاجتماع
كان يوجد فيه روح ايجابيه ولكن حتى الان
لم يتم التوصل الى حل مرضي للطرف اليمين
وطرف اليسار وما زال هناك يعني سوف يكون
هناك عده لقاءات سوف يقوم بانعقادها ربما
يكون ايضا في منزل الرئيس الاسرائيلي هذا
الاسبوع
حتى يعني ربما يحصل اي تطورات في هذا
الموضوع ولكن حتى الان الموضوع يعني لا
يوجد اي حل موجود على الطاوله بشكل نهائي
طيب لنا ماذا عن السجال واللهجه الشديده
بين بايدن ونتنياهو كيف تتناولها الصحف في
الداخل
يعني حكومه الولايات المتحده كانت منذ
البدايه يعني معترضه على هذه التعديلات
القضائيه وايضا كانت تبدي قلقها بشان
الشارع الاسرائيلي وبشان الاحتجاجات
والمظاهرات التي كانت يعني تزداد وتتصاعد
اسبوع تلوى الاخر شاهدنا عشرات الالاف من
الاسرائيليين يعني يخرجون الى الشارع في
تل ابيب والقدس يعني معترضين على هذه
التعديلات القضائيه كانت هناك محاولات
كبيره من الولايات المتحده للضغط على
بنيامين نتنياهو كان هناك ايضا الرئيس
الامريكي اجراء اتصال شخصي مع بنيامين
نتنياهو وقال له يعني على ما يبدو ان
الامور تتصاعد الى الاسوا ونصحه بان يقوم
بتوقيف هذه التعديلات القضائيه والغائها
وليس فقط تاجيلها الى بعض الاعياد
اليهوديه وهذا على ما يبدو ما اغضب
بنيامين نتنياهو وقال له يعني نحن فعليا
لن يكون هناك ضغط على او ضغط من الولايات
المتحده على اسرائيل لالغاء هذه التعديلات
القضائيه وان اسرائيل سوف تقوم بما يناسب
لها وايضا قد صرح الرئيس الولايات المتحده
بينه لا يوجد لديه نيه باستضافه بنيامين
نتنياهو حتى الان يعني يوجد هناك تهديد من
اكثر دوله اكثر دوله يعني مؤيده لاسرائيل
وداعمه لاسرائيل راينا ذلك منذ سنوات ولكن
اليوم هي تعارض اسرائيل ويوجد يعني حساسيه
او على ما يبدو شكرا لك من امام الكنيسه
مراسله العربيه لانا
من اسرائيل الى موسكو حيث قال وزير
الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبد اللهيان
ان روسيا لعبت دورا اهما في المفاوضات حول
استعاده الاتفاق النووي الايراني مع
مجموعه الاربعه زائد واحد في فيينا وهو
امر يعتزم مناقشته مع وزير الخارجيه
الروسي سيرجي لافروف خلال زيارته الى
روسيا ونقلت الوكاله عن عبد الهيان في
بدايه زياره للعاصمه الروسيه ان الباب
الاستئناف المفاوضات النوويه الايرانيه
مفتوح وان احد مواضيع المحادثات مع بذل
الجهود لاعاده الاطراف الى الامتثال
لاحكام خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه
رحله ترانزيت بسيطه تشعل توترا بين واشنطن
وبكين فقد طالب مكتب شؤون تايوان الصيني
طلب امريكا بعدم السماح لرئيسه
وعدم عقد اي لقاءات رسميه معها وقالت
المتحدثه باسم المكتب في مؤتمر صحفي ان
مرور ساي في الولايات المتحده هو استفزاز
متعمد وانتهاك خطير لمبدا الصين الواحده
اذا اتصلت برئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي
مكارثي سيكون هذا استفزازا اخر ينتهك بشكل
خطير مبدا الصين الواحده ويؤذي سياده
الصين وسلامتها الاقليميه ويدمر السلامه
والاستقرار في مضيق تايوان نحن نعارض ذلك
بشده وسنتخذ بالتاكيد اجراءات للرد بحزم
ولكن قبل كل ذلك كانت حذرت الولايات
المتحده الصين من اي رد فعل مبالغ فيه على
توقف لرئيسه تايوان في نيويورك خلال
توجهها الى امريكا الوسطى وفيلوس انجلوس
في طريقي عودتها وقال مسؤول امريكي كبير
انه لا يوجد اي سبب على الاطلاق يجعل
الصين تستخدم ذلك كداريعه لرد فعل المبالغ
فيه او لممارسه مزيد من الضغط على تايوان
موضحا ان توقفها في الاراضي الامريكيه لا
ينتهك باي شكل سياسه الولايات المتحده
بشان الصين واحده وانها مجرد نقطه عبور
مؤكدا انها زياره خاصه لا رسميه اما من
جانبها شددت رئيس التايوان على ان تايبي
لن تخضع لاي ضغوط خارجيه ومصممه على توسيع
علاقاتها الدوليه مشيره الى ان تايوان
مستمره في المضي قدما نحو تحقيق سيادتها
الكامله وحريتها
حيوان تايوان هي تايوان في العالم ان
قياده تايوان الى العالم وجلب العالم الى
تايوان هدف مهم لادارتنا الضغط الخارجي لن
يمنعنا من اصرارنا على احتضان العالم
نتحلى بالهدوء والثقه والصلابه وعدم
الاستفزاز ستسير تايوان بثبات على طريق
الحريه والديمقراطيه الى العالم
مستمرون بعد الفاصل ونتابع الحكومه
البريطانيه تحارب التسول وغاز الضحك
[موسيقى]
الجيش الاوكراني ينفي ان تقدم روسي في
باخموت وزلنسكي يحذر من تداعيات وخيمه
لخساره المدينه
مع استمرار المفاوضات حول التعديلات
القضائيه في اسرائيل رسائل جديده اللهجه
بين بايدن ونتنياهو
واشنطن تحضر بكين من اي رد فعل على زياره
رئيس التايوان والصين تعتبر الترانزيت
استفزازا متعمدا
وتقرير يحذر بان الذكاء الاصطناعي سيحل
محل 300 مليون وظيفه بدوام كامل على الاقل
في المستقبل
احييكم من جديد اعلنا مجلس نظارات البجى
جناح ترك اعلن يوم الاول من ابريل موعدا
للاغلاق الشامل لشرق السودان وذلك رفضا
للاتفاق السياسي وقال المجلس في بيان انه
يقف ضد اي عمليه سياسيه او جدول زمني
لتكوين حكومه يرفضها 90% من الشعب
السوداني على حد قوله وطالب بيان مجلس
البجاء القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع
بالوقوف على مسافه واحده من الجميع
تتزايد المخاوف تدريجيا مشاهدينا في اوساط
الموظفين والعمال في مختلف انحاء العالم
من ان ياتي يوم ويتم الاستغناء عنهم بشكل
نهائي خاصه وان تقريرا صادرا عن بنك
الاستثمار جولد من ساكس قالها قال ان
الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن ان يحل محل ما
يعادل 300 مليون وظيفه بدوام كامل في خلال
الفتره المقبله وبحسب التقرير فان تقنيات
الذكاء الاصطناعي ستقوم بمهام ربع الوظائف
في الولايات المتحده وفي اوروبا لكن هذا
قد يعني ايضا وظائف جديده وانتعاشا في
الانتاجيه وفي النهايه قد يؤدي هذا الى
زياده القيمه السنويه الاجماليه للسلع
والخدمات المنتجه عالميا بنسبه 7% ويقول
التقرير ان الذكاء الاصطناعي القادر على
انشاء محتوى مشابه بصوره كبيره لما ينتجه
البشر يمثل تقدما كبيرا ويمكن استخدامه
لانجاز 46% من المهام الاداريه و44
من المهام القانونيه لكن هذه النسب
ستتراجع في قطاع البناء الى 6% فقط واربعه
في قطاع الصيانه
تعتزم حكومه ريشيسوناك تقديم قانون يهدف
الى مكافحه ما تسميها السلوك غير
الاجتماعي ويتضمن المشروع حزمه اجراءات من
بينها منع بيع غاز الضحك ومكافحه التسول
الذي انتشر مع الازمه الاقتصاديه بالاضافه
الى صلاحيات اوسع لاصحاب البيوت لطرد
المستاجرين
خطه عمل جديده طرحتها حكومه ريشيسوناك
لمواجهه ما تسميه السلوك المعادي للمجتمع
فضمن اصلاح قطاع ايجار السكن سيكون بوسع
ملاك المنازل طرد مستاجريهم الذين ينتهكون
معايير السلوك الاجتماعي كالحفلات الصاخبه
او طاعات المخدرات او يتاخرون في سداد
ايجارهم
اصلاحاتنا صحيحه ومتناسبه ومتوازنه وسنعمل
على تقويه اسسها وعلى اصحاب العقارات
استخدامها لاستعاده ملكيتها بما في ذلك
عندما يكون المستاجرون مخطئين
الائتلاف الصحي للمستاجرين لطالما دعا
الحكومه الى تعديل نظام الايجار لحصول
مستاجرين على مرافق مناسبه وصالحه
الاستخدام والغاء طردهم دون سبب مع انشاء
هيئه لتسويه النزاعات بسرعه
اعتقد ان احد اهداف هذا التشريع كما تقول
الحكومه هو اعاده التوازن للنظام لصالح
المستاجرين بشكل طفيف لان اصحاب العقارات
في الوقت الحاليه يتمتعون بالكثير من
القوه في التصرف في ممتلكاتهم ويعود سبب
ذلك الى الطلب الكبير جدا على العقارات
المؤجره
التشريع الجديد سيحد ايضا من المتسولين
الذين زاد عددهم مع الازمه الاقتصاديه في
شوارع بريطانيا يتكسبون من روادها باساليب
ابتزاز تزعج الماره
اذا ما ارادت الحكومه القضاء على التسول
فعليها ان توفر ما يلزم وهو القضاء على
الفقر
ليس بامكان المتسولين كسب لقمه عيشهم من
خلال العمل وما لم يؤذون الماره فلا ارى
مشكله في تسولهم
بموجب نهج عدم التسامح المطلق سيتم حظر
غاز اكسيد النيتروس المعروف بغاز الضحك في
رساله واضحه الى عصابه التخويف التي تتجول
في الشوارع الرئيسيه والمنتزهات وتغمرها
بمخدر العبوات الفارغه وتزعج النسب
بسلوكها المعادي تعتبر الحكومه خطه العمل
المناهضه للسلوك الذي ينتهك حق الفرد في
العيش بامان امرا بالغ الاهميه ولن تتوانى
في تعاطيها مع الجريمه والسلوك المزعج
الذي يسبب البؤس للناس مصطفى زاروه
العربيه لندن
تيك توك يدخل على خط تصنيع السلاح نعم
مشاهدينا فقد قالت احدى اكبر الشركات
المصنعه للذخيره في اوروبا انها تواجه
تحديا في التوسعه للمخطط لها مما عرقل
ايضا من تلبيه احتياجات اوكرانيا
المتزايده على الذخيره والسبب هو شركه تيك
توك كيف نتابع هذه الذخائر على المح
اك هذه المقاطع نعم مقاطع تيك توك قد تهدد
تزويد اوكرانيا بالذخائر شركه نامو لتصنيع
الذخائر النرويجيه احدى اكبر الشركات
المصنعه للذخيره في اوروبا قد لا تتمكن من
تلبيه طلب الاوكرانيين المتزايد على
الذخائر اما السبب فيعود لمركز بيانات تيك
توك الجديد الذي يحتكر ويستهلك الكهرباء
في المنطقه القريبه من اكبر مصنع ذخيره في
النرويج ووفق صحيفه
شركتنا للتوسع تتعارض مع جهود تيك توك
لتحسين صورتها في مواجهه عدد متزايد من
عمليه الحظر في جميع انحاء العالم من خلال
استيعاب بيانات الاوروبيين محليا بشكل
اكبر من بينها النرويج اصلا
وهي خطوه تريد منها تيك توك ارضاء
المشرعين الاوروبيين بتخزين بيانات
المستخدم الاوروبي محليا وتقليل نقل
البيانات خارج المنطقه الشركه اعلنت عن
خطط لفتح مراكز بيانات جديده في ايرلندا
وفي منطقه هامار في النرويج الرئيس
التنفيذي لشركه نام القلق اعتبر ان النمو
المستقبل والحرب الدائره قد يعرقلهما
تخزين مقاطع الفيديو الخاصه بالقطط مثلا
في جامعه دورام البريطانيه اكتشف علماء
فلك واحدا من اكبر الثقوب السوداء على
الاطلاق الثقب الاسود الذي تم اكتشافه
فائق الحجم بكتله تقدر بحوالي
32.7 مليار ضعف كتله الشمس ما يجعله اكبر
بحوالي ثمانيه الاف مره من الثقب الاسود
الهائل في مركز مجره درب التبانه وبحسب
موقع
مشاهدينا الثقب الاسود الهائل يبعد حوالي
2.7 مليار سنه ضوئيه من الارض وتم اكتشافه
عن طريق انحناء الضوء اثناء انحراف مساره
ويذكر ان اكبر ثقب اسود تم اكتشافه على
الاطلاق هو طن 618 عام 1970 وبحجم يقرب
حوالي 40 مليار كتله شمسيه اضافه الى
الوجبات الرمضانيه التي اعتاد بنك الغذاء
اللبناني على توزيعها في شهر رمضان
المبارك على العائلات المحتاجه يقدم هذا
العام ايضا صناديق تحتوي على منى لبنانيه
تستفيد من ثمنها ربات منازل بحاجه الى دعم
مادي يؤكد بنك الغذاء ان مساعدته تستفيد
او مساعدته تستفيد منها العائلات
اللبنانيه حصرا مع ازدياد نسب الفقر وحصول
اللاجئين على مساعدات من المؤسسات الدوليه
[موسيقى]
تنظيم حسان ساعات وهي تحرك قدر اليقطين
سلمونه التي تحضرها ليست للاستخدام
المنزلي بل ليتم توزيعها على عائلات
محتاجه خلال الشهر الصوم وام حسان ليست
افضل حالا فهي المعيله الوحيده لثلاثه
اطفال لجات الى تعاونيه الخياره التي تعمل
على تمكين المراه علا تؤمن مصدر رزق
يتماشى مع دورها كربه منزل الاب للاولاد
مش موجود والوضع الاقتصادي
ومجبوره انا ما فيش غيري انا قدام الاولاد
يعني انا بدي انجبر يكون الباي والام يعني
اعمل الدوره توصلنا مع جمعيات بتوعنا
بسلامه الغذاء وخضعوا السوايا عنا كلياتهم
لتدريبات نحن عنا 16 ست بالتعاونيه وبلشنا
نشتغل على التصنيع المونه البيتيه
والكيتارينك
وهالشيء هذا كليته يساعد الصبايا انه بلشت
تطلع من جو البيت تعلمت على موني جديده
على تصنيع جديد
بنقو الغذاء اللبناني الذي يكثف من
مساعداته الغذائيه خلال الشهر الصوم اختار
تعاونيه الخيار لتامين الحصص التموينيه
للعائلات المحتاجه
وبذلك يكون قد ساعد ايضا النسوه القرويه
اما المنتوجات فتؤمنها تعاونيه الخياره من
المزارعين اللبنانيين لتساعدهم ايضا على
تصريف محاصيلهم الزراعيه
بسنه 23
الطلبات للمساعدات كثير كترت والجمعيات ما
بقى تقدر تتحمل عدد الاشخاص اللي طالبه
مساعدات بالمقابل المساعدات اللي كنت
تجينا من خارج لبنان ومن لبنان كتير قلت
فعم بيكون عنا كتير صعوبات لنقدر نوفي او
نوفر
مساعدات لكل العالم اللي عم تقدم طلب
جربنا قد ما فينا بدعم من عده متبرعين
نحافظ على العدد اللي رح يقدر يستفيد منها
هذا الشهر الف ومئتين وخمسين عائله
لبنانيه ستستفيد من صناديق تحتوي
لبنانيه كما وسيؤمن بنك الغذاء ايضا وجبات
افطار طيله شهر الصيام من خيرات الارض في
القرى الى العائلات المحتاجه في المدن
اطلق مايكل غذاء اللبناني حمله جديده من
التبرعات لمساعده العدد الاكبر من الاسر
خلال شهر رمضان المبارك غنوه يتيم العربيه
البقاع
قصص اللاجئين السوريين تعود الى الشاشه
وهذه المره في لبنان التي يجسدها مسلسل
النار بالنار المسلسل الجدلي المكون من 30
حلقه يعرض موضوع النزوح والمشاكل التي
ترافقه يجمع عابد فهد وكاريس بشار وجورج
خباز بالاضافه الى اهم الفنانين السوريين
واللبنانيين المزيد في فقره كواليس مع سهى
الوعل واعداد ايهم القاسم
[موسيقى]
حاول يكون عزيز عامل شيدو السوريه
بدنا نقطع الكهرباء عن الحاره
مرحبا من اكثر الاعمال المثيره للفضول هذا
العام في رمضان مسلسل للنار بالنار والسبب
جراه موضوعه واللي تتناول بعض المشاكل
اللي تواجه اللاجئين السوريين في لبنان
بجراه كبيره من بطوله النجمين عابد فهد
وكاريس بشار حاولنا نوصل فكره جدا موضوعيه
ونكون جدا وسطيين وما نكون ميالين لطرف
اكثر من طرف كونه خلفيه هذا المسلسل بيحكي
عن الصراع السوري اللبناني يلي سببه
بالاساس سياسي والناس يتبنوه بس على
الصعيد الانساني بتكتشف انه حقيقه ما في
خلاف على الصعيد الانساني ولكن في رواسب
عديده
والام وجروح وطبعا نزلت على المنطقه
الاساسيه اللي هي عايشه فيها بسوريا
اكيد كل السوريين بيعرفوها اسمها الشيخ
محي الدين ومن هناك انطلقت بانه مريم كيف
بتمشي وليش هيك بتمشي المسلسل المؤلف من
30 حلقه من تاليف رامي كوسا واخراج محمد
عبد العزيز يشارك فيه بالبطوله ايضا
الفنانين جورج خباز الطوني عيسى زينه مكي
طارق تميم وكثير غيرهم ويحظى حاليا بنسبه
مشاهده عاليه وسط الكثير من الجدل على
مواقع التواصل ما بين فئات تعزز الاحداث
كواقع وافئات تصف بالمبالغه الرؤيه الفنيه
والمعالجه انا برايي انه كيف ممكن نحن
نتطرق لهذه الاشكاليه بدون ما يكون له شكل
اخباري او نيوز يعني كيف تتم معالجته
دراميا هون اهميه هذا المشروع مسلسل نار
بالنار بعتقد اول مسلسل مشترك لبناني سوري
مبرر عم يحكي عن هالصراع ما بين الشعبين
والصداقات كمان مش بس الصراعات فمسلسل
حقيقي جدا شخصيه انطوائيه عنده اسباب
وعنده تاريخه
بالحرب
وخاطفينو بوقتها السوريين فعنده اذا بدك
حقد كبير على السوريين وهذا الشيء بيترجمه
بتعاطيه مع الناجحين السوريين يلي بيكونوا
اللي بيجوا على على الحاره اللي هو ساكن
فيها انا
شخصيه
مواطن عادي اسمه جميل كان صحافه وهو يساري
شيوعي يعني صار عنده انكسار من الثوره
بالبلد وصار عنده انكسار من انتماءه
السياسي من خطوه السياسي اللي ماشي عليها
الحياه ما بصير تلعب معه
وهي اللحظه
اتاكدت انه ابليس اللي جواتي طلعوا
[موسيقى]
عندك ماضي
في الختام نذكر بالعناوين
الجيش الاوكراني في اي تقدم روسيا في
باخموت وزيرنسكي يحذر من تداعيات وخيمه
لخساره المدينه
مع استمرار المفاوضات حول التعديلات
القضائيه في اسرائيل رسائل شديده اللهجه
بين بايدن ونتنياهو
تحذر بكين من اي رد فعل على زياره رئيس
التايوان والصين تعتبر الترانزيت استفزازا
متعمدا
تقرير يحذر بان الذكاء الاصطناعي سيحل محل
ثمان 300 مليون وظيفه بدوام كامل على
الاقل في المستقبل
مزيد من الاخبار دوما على العربيه دوت نت
القاكم او الزميل نايف الاحمر يلقاكم على
راس الساعه في امان الله